- You want a good quote about friendship?
I've got one for ya.
There's nothing better than a friend
unless it is a friend with chocolate.
It's so true.
So, so good.
- Speaking of friends,
(upbeat music)
Donald Trump, he's not
all that big on them.
Throughout his life in
politics and business,
Trump has surrounded himself
with a very small group of people.
That group includes family,
fellow titans of industry
and some mixture of
hangers on and yes men,
and it's that last group, the
hangers on and the yes men,
that interest me most.
Good job, boss.
Because throughout his life,
Trump has proven that
there is some real value
in staying very close to him.
In his days as a real estate
developer and marketer
that value was primarily financial.
Trump, the financial whale,
dropped off enough money
to enrich those minnows
swimming beside him,
who are willing to say and do
whatever he told them to say and do.
Exhibit A: Michael Cohen.
Right?
Right.
Now as president, the
value proposition for Trump
is influence and future political gain,
and just as in his life as a business man,
Trump has attracted a small,
but extremely loyal cadre
of House members and senators
who defend him to a fault,
understanding that being close to Trump
serves their larger goals.
Okay, let's go through all
of these president's men,
and yes, they are pretty much
all men.
And we start with Matt
Gaetz, a Florida congressman
who was once described
in a terrific headline
by GQ Magazine as the
Trumpiest congressman
in Trump's Washington.
Well done.
Way back in 2013, Gaetz was in a meeting
with one-time Trump political
Svengali Roger Stone,
yes, all roads lead back to Roger Stone,
when Stone told Gaetz that
the businessman Donald Trump
would be president one day.
Quote, "I thought he had
gone one toke over the line,"
said Gaetz of Stone's predictions.
Marijuana reference.
But, Gaetz was convinced, somehow,
and became an early endorser of Trump,
and unlike so many other Republicans,
who wavered in their support
for Trump over the 2016 campaign,
Gaetz never, ever backed away
from the billionaire businessman.
- I think that the substance of this memo
absolutely implicates senior officials
of the Department of Justice and the FBI,
and I think hat it shows
that the entire Mueller investigation
should have never been
started in the first place.
- In fact, the more norms
Trump has smashed through
as a candidate and now as president,
the more Gaetz has not only leaned in
to his support for the president
but also seemed to emulate
Trump's actual behavior.
On the eve of one-time
Trump fixer Michael Cohen...
Yeah, him.
His testimony to Congress in mid-February,
Gaetz sent out a tweet
that was clearly designed
to intimidate Cohen.
Wrote Gaetz,
(whoosh)
quote,
"Hey @MichaelCohen212.
Do your wife and father-in-law
know about your girlfriends?
Maybe tonight would be a
good time for that chat.
I wonder if she'll remain
faithful when you're in prison.
She's about to learn a lot."
Dot, dot,
dot.
(whoosh)
(sighs) That's a doozy.
Gaetz later deleted that tweet,
but he did show up at Cohen's hearing
mostly to get attention,
almost excursively to get attention,
but ostensibly to try to ask
questions despite the fact
that he's actually not on the
House Oversight Committee.
(sighs heavily)
Moving on.
There are two other House members
who are super close to Trump,
and they're two peas in a pod:
Ohio's Jim Jordan and North
Carolina's Mark Meadows.
Now, the two actually
wrote a co-bylined op-ed
(whoosh)
in USA Today
in advance of the Cohen hearing,
calling it, quote, a
disservice to the public,
an affront to our democratic values
and flat-out offensive to
anyone who seeks the truth,
end quote.
(whoosh)
So who are they?
All right, well Meadows
is the current chairman
of the House Freedom Caucus,
which is Trump's base in Congress
and the most conservative
and confrontational
Republicans in the House.
Jordan actually co-founded that group
and remains very closely
affiliated with it.
Now Meadows and Jordan have
worked hammer and tongs...
I love that expression...
Since Trump was elected
to help him build his case
that there's in fact a deep state
within the Justice Department
and the broader government
that never wanted Trump to
win and, since he did win,
has worked to hamstring his effectiveness.
Now both men, Meadows and Jordan,
not only make their case for Trump
inside the walls of Congress.
They also do it on cable TV,
including Trump's pet channel,
which, of course, I
don't need tell you this,
is Fox News channel.
- The American people have a right to know
if the guy running the Justice Department
was actually talking about
doing those two things
with the guy they elected president.
They need to write...
They need answers to those questions.
- Trump has, of course, taken notice
'cause all he does is watch cable TV.
Quote, he's a champ.
I love him defending me on television.
"He is a bulldog," Trump said of Jordan
at a campaign rally in Cleveland,
just before the election.
Quote, he doesn't give a damn.
Boom, boom, boom!
Point after point!
Right?!
He's a champ.
Boom, boom, boom!
(banging)
Meadows bragged in the Cohen hearing
that he had spoken to
Trump more than 300 times.
I bet you haven't done that.
Right, right, am I right?
I'm right.
Meadows was also considered
a potential chief of staff,
Trump in the White House,
but he didn't get that job.
Now let's move over to the Senate
and the very curious
case of Lindsey Graham.
Graham ran against Trump
in the 2016 GOP primaries,
and although the South Carolina senator
was never a serious contender,
he was outspoken about his
distaste for Donald John Trump.
Said Graham of Trump on
CNN in December 2015,
quote, "He's a race-baiting,
xenophobic religious bigot.
He doesn't represent my party.
He doesn't represent the
values that the men and women
who wear the uniform are
fighting for," end quote.
Seems pretty cut and dry,
but Graham has experienced
a remarkable about face since those days.
He is now a regular golf
partner of the President's
and one of Trump's most
outspoken defenders.
Take this.
Graham almost single
handedly saved the nomination
of Brett Kavanaugh to the Supreme Court,
dragging a badly damaged
Kavanaugh across the line
with a spirited defense
of the judge's record
and character in front of the
Senate Judiciary Committee.
And, yes, Graham defended Trump
about the Cohen hearing
as well, tweeting this,
quote,
(whoosh)
Democrats' hatred of Trump is undercutting
an important foreign
policy effort and is way
out of line.
(whoosh)
That important foreign policy effort?
The summit between Kim Jong Un
and Donald Trump in Vietnam.
So, what explains Graham's 180 on Trump?
Graham himself explained it
as a desire to be relevant,
in a recent New York
Times Magazine profile,
which he probably shouldn't have said.
The desire to be relevant
is a powerful elixir
in politics and life,
and that's what explains
the closeness of all
these president's men.
They think that by staying
in Trump's good graces,
they have a better chance
of getting what they want
in policy and political terms.
And that
is the point.
We make new episodes every
Tuesday and Thursday.
Make sure to check them all out.
(upbeat music)